Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my full Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 5 Video
There were a whole bunch of storylines and Easter Eggs
that they paid off, like long running plots and more
recent stuff from, like, Rick Prime and Evil Morty.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're only like halfway through the season,
so there's still like a bunch of WTF stuff
that they'll probably save for the actual season
finale.
careful for spoilers.
If you have not seen the episode yet,
we'll start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs w wtf moments,
starting with the episode titled Unmoored
Rick in which is a reference to the Clint Eastwood
Western movie Unforgiven,
which itself is a revisionist movie
that upends a lot of the stereotypical Western movie
tropes, up to the point that that movie came out
about the black and white nature of absolute good,
always triumphing over evil in a lot of classic
Western movies, basically painting things
in a more morally gray brush where terrible people
sometimes do good things and vice versa.
And it's meant to be a more direct reference
to the evil Morty and see 137 Rick's story arc
where again they did this during season five,
they portray Evil Morty as doing more heroic
things like helping Rick
but also while he's doing that, he comments
sarcastically about how he's not called nice Morty
or good Morty for a reason.
Like he's honest about being more morally ambiguous yet
winds up helping Rick capture and kill Rick Prime.
he even implies at the end of the episode
that he might ask for Rick's help in the future.
Again, like they might team up again
in a future episode in during the episode.
Rick, on his side of things, also treats evil Morty
with a certain measure of respect.
generally, the episode tries to continue to reinforce
the idea that inside the Rick and Morty multiverse,
there's no such thing
as someone who is completely good or completely evil.
Everyone is just shades of gray.
Maybe not.
So Mobius though. R.I.P.
Everyone Poor went out for slow Mobius
just in terms of big movies, story parodies
for the episode,
just overall kind of turns into like a saw parody
with the Cube movies,
which is also a bit of like a horror sci
fi franchise in kind of a trap based conceit
crossed with Battle Royale and The Unforgiven movie
itself, basically with the purpose
of paying off the saga of Rick trying to find and kill
Rick Prime, the Rick who killed his wife, Diane,
and his original Beth when he was younger,
basically causing the series of events
that turned him into the version of See 137, Rick,
that we saw at the beginning of season one.
also at the end of the episode
asking the question, who is Rick
if he is not trying to avenge his dead wife?
Like, what is his life going to be going forward now?
Like, what is his grand purpose
now that Rick Prime is dead, funny enough, evil Morty
also kind of acknowledges that he went through this
same kind of arc after he escaped the central fire.
And I curve like he also implies that he finds his life
kind of meaningless and empty now, like,
what do you do now that you've achieved your goal
To be fair, though, Dan Harmon did say that
Rick and Morty could continue
kind of like The Simpsons forever.
I don't think that will happen.
Like it won't continue forever,
but they're supposedly making a Rick and Morty movie.
Now we know it's going to go at least ten seasons.
so like there's a ton more actual story.
So I'm sure they'll have some funny way
of referencing that by episode six.
Like, yeah, this big emotional moment
for Rick at the end of the episode.
but you do remember a lot of times they'll do
the one off episodes right after the canonical episodes
where it seems like the characters
kind of get their emotions reset a little bit,
like they might briefly acknowledge some of the trauma
they experience in the previous episode,
but they're mostly back to normal.
Like a lot of non serialized television. generally.
This episode was super canonical,
wrapping up a number of major
storylines, some not totally,
totally wrapping up the Rick Prime saga.
At least that's been going on in the background
since season three.
it did not totally wrap up the evil Morty saga.
Like I said, it really only brought him back
temporarily leaving at the end of the episode
with a teaser that nobody should come looking for him.
But he might need Rick
because he's different in the future.
Like I might use that in future,
implying that they'll team up again.
maybe not to like season eight or something like that.
They don't bring evil
Morty back many, many times within the same season.
at least not anymore.
They also use the episode to pay off a lot of
the teasers about what the wider multiverse looks like.
What happened to evil Morty
after he used the yellow Portal fluid and did
a tour of the wider multiverse, which is kind of like
the Wild West compared to the much more tame
looking dimensions in the central finite curve
that we usually see week to week on the show.
it gets super crazy beyond the central finite curve.
the actual opening scene
is basically the entire full backstory of evil.
Morty They also confirm a lot of theories during this
that people had about his backstory.
This started after he debuted back in season one.
So a lot of these fan theories actually went way back
like ten years ago at this point.
That's how long ago it was.
They show that evil Morty started out
as just like a regular Morty who got sick of his Rick
abusing him during their adventures.
Notice that the final mission that they went on before
he rebelled against him was to get more crystals,
which is sort of a callback to the earlier
this season when they revealed C-1 37,
Rick had the main morty dealing crystals for him
on the side for what seemed like a while.
I think they just want to suggest
that potentially this main morty
is also getting close to that breaking point
that evil Morty did.
Like at any moment, he could actually just be pushed
over the edge inside their garage.
For the most part,
everything looks very similar to what it did
in the first couple of seasons of Rick and Morty.
like they want it to seem very,
very similar to the main version of Rick and Morty
that we've been seeing this whole time.
this Rick also has the same kind of secret fridge
that they have in all their garages.
We saw earlier this season.
he's got some kind of dodecahedron
that says do not open until X.
I'm not sure what's inside it.
You can put your theories about that in the comments
below.
He's got the same floating eyeball in that green fluid
that we saw in our Rick's fridge earlier this season.
same brand of beer, but the whole idea is that evil
Morty is trying to get him drunk
so that he can hijack and take over his body.
Basically Evil Morty's bedroom is pretty much
the same as are Morty's bedroom.
He's making the eyepatch device that he wore,
allowing him to remotely control his Rick,
then basically executes his plan, taking over his mind,
controlling his body, notice
when he goes to actually execute the plan.
This, Rick also repeats the 100 year
rant from earlier on the show.
They travel to the citadel
of Rick's and begins slowly
constructing that device that we saw them using
during season one, slowly
going around, capturing more and more bodies
to power his field, hiding their base,
going through a lot of the different Rick's too.
they started the Morty Agency because that's a business
at the Citadel designed to help Rick get new.
Morty's a callback to Rick's free replacement, Morty
that they offered him during season one.
evil Morty.
Looks like he's mostly collecting the disaffected.
Morty's first look the most unhappy Morty.
Probably
because they're easier for him to get away from there.
Rick's as opposed to the happy ones
who would be more likely to try and stop him.
The reason why he's erasing the file of this unhappy
Morty are the ones that he steals
is because he doesn't want there to be records of them
inside the Citadel system.
He doesn't want people to come looking for them.
then they basically replay the events of season
one episode ten, the very first Evil
Morty episode, adding a few new scenes,
a new context to those events from evil.
Morty's perspective, go to a bunch of other realities
while they're collecting different Morty
in different Rick's.
This is a reference to Prince's Purple Rain.
Like this whole dimension is a Purple Rain dimension
where they all dress
like Prince does during that album.
Even their stuff is purple.
The dog Sniffles is dressed
like Prince two On the wall.
The picture of the Corvette is a reference to Prince's
song Little Red Corvette.
notice.
They're also eating spaghetti like they have the same
spaghetti nights that we saw earlier on the show.
This family hasn't discovered that the spaghetti
is actually made of people in the next reality.
Snuggles is dressed like that one picture of the rock
with the turtleneck and chain.
everyone in this reality are wearing turtleneck
versions of their clothes, like this
entire universe is based on that rock meme.
they show how evil Morty's
Rick continues to try and break free of his control
and kill himself, eventually welcoming
the Morty's at the facility, rebelling and killing him
because he wants to be free of evil, Morty,
even if it means his death They show that
at the end of that episode, Evil Morty was rescued
by one of the council members at the Citadel of Rick's.
We saw him sitting on the council later in the episode.
Who gives evil Morty council member robes,
making it seem like evil.
Morty had been working with someone
on the inside of the council
with members secretly before this, probably helping him
execute his plans.
Hijacking, stealing all these different Morty's
and Rick's So it sounds like he was able
to convince some of the council members
to turn on the rest of the council.
they show what happened to him.
After the end of season one,
he just went to the Citadel and lived a quiet life
until they started having elections again.
we basically see the events of season three.
Episode seven.
remember his whole Citadel takeover plan,
which is a ruse he orchestrated
in order to gain access to the control chamber
for the central finite curve,
allowing him to escape it,
He didn't care about ruling over the Citadel.
He didn't really care about anything that was happening
in the central finite group.
He just wanted to escape.
They replayed the events of season five.
When he did escape
blowing up the central finite curve containment device,
he didn't blow out the curve itself.
He he just blew up the barrier preventing people
from leaving the central finite curve.
Then this is one of the few episodes
that you notice that skips
the regular longer intro
and just plays the title screen.
then they basically show what happened to him
on the other side of that yellow portal.
After the events of season five.
part of the idea with his portals being yellow
is that they're made from the blood of Rick's like,
It has something to do with Rick's DNA.
I think the idea is that the green portals
are just meant to work within the central finite curve.
the yellow portals and all the other colored portals
that we see later in the episode,
or for wilder space outside the central finite curve.
and they basically reveal the wider multiverse
outside the central finite curve
is just chaotic space
with no semblance of any kind of order.
All the main characters exist, but in vastly different
forms like there's still versions of Rick's
in the family still exist, but they're very different
as opposed to the alternate versions
we see inside the central finite curve,
where they all kind of look similar.
there's a bunch of different colors of portal fluids,
different shapes of portals.
There's a bunch of open wormholes
like the ones we saw on previously on the show,
Naturally occurring Wormholes Between Dimensions.
They also explained Rick is to blame for some of these
as he's searching for Rick Prime
starting to merge different dimensions, also affecting
the fabric of reality and doing
so these versions of the family,
they kill each other with different portals
seem like parodies of The Jetsons and Evil.
Morty reveals that he's currently on a mission
to get some special type of crystal from this monster
to power his bunker device,
like the shield around his giant bunker.
is basically like an island in space
that he's been living out for the past couple of years.
Meant to be kind of like a paradise oasis,
kind of like Thanos, his garden planet
at the end of Infinity War in Avengers Endgame,
Notice the travels back into the central finite
curve to get to his oasis planet.
most of the aliens, the monsters
we encounter throughout this part of the episode
are brand new with a few exceptions, like this monster
we saw previously on the show.
I think his robot at this plant here
is meant to be a parody of The Jetsons Butler robot.
Just because we saw Jetsons
parodies earlier in the episode.
in the whole idea is that what Rick is doing?
Basically fracking the multiverse
looking for Rick Prime is affecting his shield
here, causing it to be breached by all these monsters,
these other asteroids And that's ultimately
why he winds up helping Rick
because he wants to get back to his quiet, alone time.
And he feels like if he helps
Rick achieve his goal of killing finding Rick Prime,
then he'll stop messing with the wider multiverse, stop
affecting reality this way, and he'll be left alone.
So essentially evil.
Morty is doing this because he wants peace and quiet,
not because he wants to actually help Rick
and do something good.
I'm not sure what this spaceship is
meant to be a reference to.
It looks like it's from either
a video game or another movie.
If you think you know right up below in the comments.
But I love that Rick created a massive spaceship.
Look, this looks huge, huge and really complicated
just for combining all these different dimensions,
like merging different dimensions.
Looking for Rick Prime, notice on his monitor.
There's a same depiction of the central finite curve
because Rick Prime is in the central finite curve.
Morty mentions the subbasement from previous episodes.
We visited again a couple times in this episode.
Rick even shuts it down at the end of the episode
to They explain the basic mechanics of how he's
searching for Rick Prime basically grabbing
all the versions of Rick Prime that are close to him
or copies of him
but it's actually evil Morty who shows up and helps him
perfect
the device, implying that he's smarter than C1 37.
Rick is smarter than Rick.
Prime there couple moments like that during the episode
two where he references being smarter than them.
Notice he references the events of Pickle Rick, Rick
also jokes that the events of the season five finale
made him a fan of evil.
Morty I think there's also meant to be a meta
reference to the episode in real life
because it was super popular with the fans.
Like Season four was not that popular
in terms of seasons.
Overall Season five finale wound up being super popular
they capture Rick Prime's Final Decoy,
which is a trap
designed to capture anyone who got too close to him.
This is where the episode turns into like
the Saw parody makes with the cube in the Battle Royale
parodies.
all trying to escape the different chambers
while trying to be the last man standing.
some of these other Rick's here
are just generic parodies,
but one of these seems like a James Bond British Rick.
This one they call a nice Rick whose only plight
in all this about doing terrible things like,
yeah, I'm definitely going to kill you,
but I'm going to be nice and tell you about it.
this one is obviously a very direct Indiana Jones
Rick parody.
Rick Prime basically confirms that he kills C1
37 Rick's wife, Diane,
out of pure spite
because he felt like Rick was acting superior to him.
and he also engineered the device to kill
all of Rick's wives across the wider multiverse.
explaining why we've never actually seen
a version of Rick's wife alive in present day.
That's been a question
that fans have had since season one.
Like how come we've never seen Rick's wife?
Is there a version out there?
The answer now is no.
To be fair, Rick Prime kept like body parts from her.
He used to make cyborgs to mess
with other Rick's recapture, but
it's not his actual wife being back alive.
they also confirmed the long running fan theory
that Rick based the voice of his
air garage and his ship's voice on his wife's voice.
But at the end of the episode Rick Prime
also references this idea they sound exactly alike.
She sounds just like our wife.
A lot of fans
basically said the same thing after season three
Episode one like, Wow, his ship
sounds exactly like Rick's wife.
they imply AC 137 Rick
is an inferior Rick with the Omega device
name like only inferior.
Rick's know about it. He's like, Well,
I heard about it from another Rick.
Yes, that's the reason why I learn about it
Later in the episode,
though, Rick Prime
basically says that the two of them are like the peak.
Rick's like the richest versions
of Rick across the entire multiverse
because they're the only two that originally came up
with portal devices meaning every other version of Rick
in the multiverse, either got the technology from them
or from another Rick who got it from them.
they kind of referenced this phenomenon
when they did the backstory for Rick in season
six and showed that he originally helped
create the citadel of Rick's.
So a bunch of those Rick's got the technology from him.
then they start the Battle Royale parody,
pitting them against each other.
See? 137 Rick is correct that Rick Prime is lying about
giving them Diane back
because she's a cyborg designed to mess with them.
They also reveal that evil Morty has upgraded
his body like Rick with Inspector Gadget,
like weapons built into his body.
We see a bunch of those weapons later
in the episode two.
the whole idea, too,
is these meant to be the riskiest version of Morty.
So that's why so much of him is so similar to Rick.
That's why they feel like they're the same and evil.
Morty also references this phenomenon
at the end of the episode, he also briefly jokes
that the main morty is more evil than him
when he tries to double cross him.
and I love the joke about the turds and pizzas
and how it confuses Morty.
Like you're just meant to be a random joke
that morning.
Just gets really hung up on like Howard turds
like pizzas Dan
Harmon said in real life that a lot of this happened
at like fan conventions the first couple of seasons.
Like they'd have really weird one off jokes
that fans would get really hung up on
The cyborg jokes about Rick
sucking at eating Tang and his junk being super smelly.
He also makes it sound like those aren't lies.
Like, how dare you reveal that
when they come back to the subbasement lair?
If it wasn't clear this Rick
and Stacy's behind them is a version
that he was using to try and track break time.
That's the reason why it's gone.
At the end of the episode, when he shuts the lab down,
he doesn't need to track them anymore
because he killed them.
So he doesn't need the extra copy.
And he has separate backup copies of himself
on different levels of the subbasement.
Notice when he pulls up the more accurate map looking
for Rick Prime, He's using his butts to track him.
That's a reference back to the season six episode
where you see the version,
the test tube shaking his bare ass.
Adam this is meant to be
a map of the specific dimension where real Rick Prime's
weapon is located, then he confirms
where he keeps his ship inside the house.
When you don't see it up in the garage,
even Morty explains that he's afraid of Rick actually
succeeding in his goal of killing Rick Prime in there,
becoming so depressed because his life has no meaning
in trying to end all existence
because his life has no purpose anymore.
So why does anything matter?
So ultimately, he wants to tell Rick
not at a desire to help him,
to prevent him from doing something worse
if he actually succeeds
and because he wants the plans for the omega weapon,
when they mention Rick killing himself,
he actually tried to do something similar
to what Rick Prime did,
killing all the versions of himself
across the multiverse during season two.
After the original Unity episode, Dan Harmon
and the writers explained that this device
was powered by Portal fluid, designed to sync up
every version of Rick from across the multiverse
and kill all of them at the same time
because he was so depressed.
But he got drunk. It missed his head. So he survived.
That's what Rick Perry meant earlier when he said that
when he creates something, it actually works correctly
because he created a similar device
to kill all the different Diane's.
And it actually worked.
then this whole sequence with Rick Prime's larger
weapon feels like a parody of a video game,
but I can't remember which one.
Let me know in the comments if you think you know what
all these characters are references to
in this giant sphere, it almost feels kind of like Halo
or Mass Effect, something similar to that the reason
why Rick Prime is like Rick but with free time is
because he doesn't have a family with him.
they reveal that season 37,
Rick is known across the multiverse as dead wife Rick.
Like all the Rick's have some moniker
like Indiana Jones.
Rick, this one is dead wife Rick.
then the first member of the family
that Rick Prime Kills is slow.
Mobius,
who was the last feature during Rick's business.
He's canonically Rick's uncle
and he's a time lord with the ability to slow time,
which they make a couple of jokes about.
He's kind of meant to be a doctor Who parody,
as in the Time Lords.
they also reference his wife
to set up the Post-Credits scene and explain
that the device erases them from existence
when it gets use so that his family almost forgets
that he ever existed, only remembering him
because of the pictures they have of him.
That's why his wife gets the tattoos of him
so that she won't forget their big inspector gadget.
Like it's really crazy.
Like it turns into like a giant video game
kind of fight.
But stopping the bullets is more of a matrix reference.
They remind you, Rick Prime has a healing factor,
kind of like Wolverine and Deadpool.
But there are limits.
Like eventually they break them when he's not able to
heal the damage that they do to him they reveal evil.
Morty's eyepatch device can also read people's brains
and warn him early about attacks
that are coming before they happen.
The Corrado Rick is a total recall reference
and the reason why evil Morty's eyepatch can't scan
Kuro Rick's brain is a joke about Coto during
the Total Recall movie having a really powerful mind.
They confirmed that C 137 Morty is Rick Prime's
original Morty,
which they also revealed back during season six
when they were kind of setting up this whole back
story, retelling the story about how C 137 Rick
actually came from another reality originally
and Rick Prime is actually the original C 137
Rick this Rick just moved in to his family's home.
That's how they explained the backstory
with Beth saying that you just disappeared
for a bunch of my life
and then showed up one day because he didn't show up.
it was the Rick who had his family killed showing up
and living in Rick Prime's house.
but remember the C-130 seven dimension.
That version of the family was from the Cronenberg
dimension.
they already moved dimensions multiple times, settling
with different versions of the family.
Since then, there's a quick joke about the Morty's
switching shirts when Evil Morty
swapped places with them,
but in reality they were the exact same shirt,
so it shouldn't matter which shirt that they wear.
Evil Morty kills all of Rick Prime's back a body
so that he can't hot bodies again
steals the plans for the Omega device
and noticed the codename
for the device is booger aids V2,
which is a callback to Morty's my in-laws.
In all the random vile names Rick gives to everything
Evil Morty implies again
that he's smarter than all the Rick's
when he says that he'd be the Batman to Rick Prime's
Robin if they were to team up,
he saves C1 37 Rick's life
so that he can finish dealing with Rick Prime
killing the stopping Rick from messing with reality
so the evil Morty can find some actual solitude
and peace without having to be interrupted
by more of Rick's grander, crazier plans.
remember, that was the real reason for helping him
do this so that he could find some more peace.
Like stop messing with reality
so that I can just chill out on my garden planet.
Rick beats Rick prior to death
in the way they treat it.
In the episode.
Like Evil, Morty mentions
that they wanted to seem like he's permitted.
But then they reference Rick feeling empty inside
like his life no longer has any purpose.
Evil Morty implies that he went through
a similar type of effect after season five.
like, what do you do with your life
now that you've achieved your grand goal?
Couple more big WTF revelations to Rick Prime implies
that had he not been the one to kill
Rick's family, Rick would have eventually been
the one to do it to his family.
like I said, the idea is that they're meant to be like
the two.
Rick is versions of Rick now Because he's dead.
See? 137 Rick is officially the richest.
Rick when evil.
Morty says he can end the Rick experiment
anytime he wants, He's just implying that he's
smarter, more powerful than all the Rick's
and thinks of their continued existence.
Kind of like a grand social experiment.
Like you are only surviving because I haven't used
this multiverse device to erase you yet.
He also explains why he's not going to use it
because he wants to use
it is more of a deterrent and he's worried that
a bunch of the summers would retaliate against him.
Not that Morty would retaliate, like he's
not worried about any of the Morty's coming out of him.
He's more worried about Summers
just because Summer is so unhinged.
then.
Like I said, when he talks about Rick
being a different kind of Rick
and he might be able to use that someday,
that's just a teaser that evil Morty
might ask him to team up with him again
and help him in the future.
then a lot of people recognize the song
that plays here.
It's Look Down from the Bridge from Rick Potion Number
nine in Rick Stare With the camera.
Zooming out on his face is a callback to Morty
doing the same thing in that original episode
If they got done burying their bodies
for the first time in the backyard, it was right
after they had moved on from Cronenberg's dimension
to a new dimension.
Rick is also kind of having the same existential crisis
that Morty was having during that episode.
Like, what does my life mean now?
What do I do with myself?
at least for now, he's kind of living in a zombie
like state.
Like I said, the next episode, Episode six
feels like it's going to be a non-canonical
like a one off episode, so he'll feel more like regular
Rick during that episode.
but as he's going around the house
while the song is playing easy space Beth is back
in during the Post-Credits scene
they pay off the slow mobius death
Basically, his wife goes to the same events
that Rick went through after his family was killed.
Pretty much all the exact same scenes, up to the point
where they're at the bar.
but she meets another version of someone
going through the same thing and they get together
working past their grief instead of doing what
Rick did, eventually living a happy life together
with both of their families, becoming one much, much
healthier, ending to the same back story
that Rick got Notice her tattoo says Never slow
because slow Mobius powers were slowing
time down is basically her spaceship is like a clock
themed version of Rick's Ship.
there were so many Easter eggs references, storylines
they paid off in the episode.
Is there any that you spotted
that I didn't talk about in the video?
Just write them below in the comments and let me know.
What do you think they're saving for the actual season
finale?
They did an episode of this big midway
through the season.
my full
Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 6 Video will post next week
after they release it.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up in the middle
of Invincible Season two episodes.
It is awesome
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of those.
Click Here for all my Loki Season 2 videos
and click here for all my Rick and Morty episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!